the assassin's creed series of video
games has become one of the most
popular and economically successful
popular media franchises in the world
spanning across over 20 games and three
decades
it's a series of action games that are
set in various historical locations
from ancient egypt to the american and
industrial revolutions
and primarily revolve around an age-long
conflict between two
semi-fictional factions the so-called
assassins
and the templars and while the more
recent games in the series can boast
about having some absolutely incredible
recreations of historical locations
perhaps some of the best in any media
ever the stories have undeniably become
pretty wacky and plenty of creative
freedom
is often employed of course this was
always the case to some degree but the
very first assassin's creed game
released in 2007
actually bases its main plot on real
historical events and
people its story is set in the 1100s and
follows al-ta'ir
an assassin from the assassin
brotherhood based in the fortress of
masiaf
and led by the so-called old man of the
mountain
referred to in the game as al-mu'alim
and all of this with the exception of
the main character
is actually based on real historical
events
the assassins are based on an actual
historical group
who functioned in this region at the
time and who had massive in syria
as one of its main strongholds so in
this video
let's explore the historical background
and
context of the famous assassins
[Music]
the assassins was a group of nizari
ismailis
a faction of revolutionary shia muslims
who established powerful fortresses and
a
fragmented state in persia and syria
from the 12th or the 11th to the
13th century and who often used as you
will see
some quite unconventional methods
military methods of
subduing their opponents but what are
nizari ismailis you may ask
let's back up a few centuries to
establish the historical background
to this story as i said the ismailis
is a branch of shia islam
in fact the second largest branch of
shia islam today
and this very famous conflict between
the sunni
and shia branches of islam
goes back very far in history but is
often
somewhat oversimplified if you want a
more thorough
introduction and an over overview of
this division between sunni and chia
you can watch my previous video on that
particular subject
but in simple terms one of the primary
probably the primary factor
in this division between shia and sunni
islam
relates to the question of authority
who is the successor or was the
successor
the rightful heir to the prophet
muhammad in terms of religious questions
these so-called sunnis eventually took
the position
that it is up to the lima religious
scholars
to determine what right practice and
right belief and so on what
orthodoxy or to answer religious
questions for the wider community
the shiites however sometimes called
alids in the early period
held that the succession to muhammad was
instead inherited by
the imams who are direct descendants of
the prophet through his daughter fatima
and her husband
ali who is also considered to be the
first of these so-called imams
there is only one imam at any given time
who has
absolute authority in religious matters
until he dies and the succession is
carried over to one of his sons
who then hands it over to his son and so
on but over the centuries things have
changed and developed of course
the shiites themselves are divided into
various
subgroups disagreeing on which line of
imams is the legitimate one
the ismailis who we are focusing on
today
appear in connection to a conflict of
succession after the sixth imam
jaffar assad the group known as the
ithna ashari or twelvers favored
jaffar's younger son musad kasim
while another group favored his eldest
son ismail
hence the name ismailis or ismailia
came to be a plot to them the ismailis
then continued to be a significant force
both politically
and intellectually for the coming
centuries
they became characterized for their
philosophical and esoteric
outlook on islam and the quran often
being referred to as the
baatiniya which can roughly be
translated to
the esoterics implementing neoplatonism
into their theology and philosophy
as well as other forms of mysticism the
ismailis have always been a very unique
voice in the intellectual tradition of
islam producing such people as the
famous safa the brethren of purity
and nasser on the political front the
ismailis soon established themselves as
a force to be reckoned with
when they founded the fatimid empire in
the early 10th century
which at the height of their power ruled
most of north africa
parts of syria and the arabian peninsula
from their base in
cairo egypt the fatimid period in egypt
and elsewhere has become known for its
great advancements in various scientific
and artistic fields
as well as a general tolerance shown
towards minority groups such as
christians and jews
the leaders of this empire the caliphs
were also the imams of the ismailis
and thus served a double function of
caliph imams
both the rulers of an empire and the
absolute religious authority for ismaili
shiites
these caliph imams would send
missionaries known as daai
to various locations around the empire
and elsewhere
and this missionary activity was
particularly successful in the wider
persian region
where a lot of these missionaries would
settle and was pretty successful in
spreading
the tawa the ismaili creed to the
population there
and this is where our story starts to
pick up
under the rule of the caliph imam
al-mustansir
there appeared on ismaili da'i in persia
by the name of
hassan sabah a very gifted man both in
philosophical
and intellectual subjects but especially
in terms of political
and military strategy in the name of the
caliph imam in cairo
hassan sabah managed to establish
himself and his ismaeli followers
as a political force in western persia
by creating or
conquering a group of strongholds or
fortresses around the region
from which their operations would be
based
this region was at the time ruled
primarily by these seljuks
staunch sunni muslims who saw the
ismailis
not only as a religious opponent but
also as a great political threat because
of the
fatimid empire further west hassan sabah
and his followers started to establish
themselves as
yet another threat to the ruling
seldricks in the region
by starting to conquer areas that was
ruled by the seljuks
while also fortifying themselves in
these mountain fortresses
a tactic that proved to be quite
ingenious and
very very successful the main fortress
which
functioned almost like a capital for the
eastern ismaili state
was al-ammut where sabah himself resided
and which would remain seemingly
unconquerable
until the coming of the mongols in the
mid-1200s
this period and the world of the
ismailis from alamout is referred to
today as the alamout
period and lasted from around 1090 when
hasan sabah established himself
to 1256 when the mongols invaded
apparently despite the relatively
fragmented nature of the state
the local population seems to be pretty
happy with the rule of the ismailis at
the time some sources claim that this
was a period of equity and justice
especially compared to earlier periods
under the rule of the seljuks
there was also a great library founded
in various of these fortresses
especially
a great library in the main fortress of
alamout
where various intellectual activities
took place
and were great intellectuals like later
on
ceredine altuzi a great philosopher and
astronomer and scientist
would spend his large amount of his life
under the patronage of the ismail imam
there at the time
but because of the very delicate
position of the ismailis at this time
being constantly under attack from
the seljuks on all sides and also by
various other
enemies there wasn't that much time for
intellectual activity or philosophical
speculation
as hassan sabah and his followers were
forced to
you know fortify themselves into these
fortresses to protect themselves and so
most of the energy and activity went
into various
military and political strategies
things got even more complicated when
the caliph imam in cairo al-mustensid
died in 1094 and there was yet another
conflict of succession
over who the next imam was the caliph
imam's oldest son
nizar had been passed over by the vizier
who had instead put another son
al-mustaili
on the throne nizad the oldest son was
later even imprisoned and
killed and this caused a huge rift in
the ismaili community
one that lasts even to this day hassan
sabah and his followers in the east
had taken the side of nizar and because
of this they
broke all ties with the new
according to them illegitimate imam
al-mustali
and thus officially became an
independent state
and all such ismailis from then on that
considered nizad to have been the
rightful successor to al-mustansir
became known as the
nizari ismailis which today makes up
the majority of ismailis in the world so
are you with me so far with the branches
and names
the nizadis is a branch of ismailism
which is a branch of shiism which of
course in itself is a branch of islam
more generally it's a good example to
show how complex religious identities
can be
in any case the newly established nizari
ismaili state
which ruled primarily from alamout but
also in spread out across various other
similar mountain fortresses would
continue to be
in conflict with the seljuks and as well
as other political forces
and despite their obvious talent in
military
strategy and political know-how
the nizadis were still vastly
outnumbered
and would have never survived a full-on
open battle or or
war in that sense and it's for this
reason that the nizaris started to apply
some more you say unique strategies for
turning the tide in their favor enter
the assassins the so-called assassins
really synonymous with the nizari
ismailis
are associated with a military strategy
undertaken
by the missouri's that sent men on
missions to assassinate political
opponents or individuals who had posed a
serious threat
to the nizari state the word assassins
is today
of course used as a general term for
anyone who commits sanctioned murder
but the term actually originates as a
term for this specific group of nizadis
there has been a general tendency to
connect this word etymologically to the
word hashashin
meaning those who smoke hashish this is
then connected to a common story that
the nizadi assassins
would smoke hashish as part of their
practice
but most historians today agree that
this is not accurate but rather a result
of later misinformation
the actual origins of the word isn't
really known it's a topic of discussion
still it may have originated with the
word hashishin referring to the smoking
of hashish
but this was some probably used in a
derogatory way and it
has been used in that way historically
for a very long time
but the word could also originally have
been
connected to the word assassin in arabic
which means the people of
principle others have even suggested it
that it may be
connected to the name hassan as in hasan
sabah
who the assassins were followers of
nonetheless the name assassins usually
refers to this entire group
of nizari ismailis who had their base in
alamout
and not necessarily to the particular
people who were
well assassins based on the modern use
of that word
instead the term that would have been
used at the time to refer to these
particular individuals who took on
secret missions of political murder
was fiday meaning those who sacrificed
themselves
because indeed taking on such a mission
to kill high-ranking political opponents
who were
often surrounded by guards in most cases
meant almost certain death
these fidaais or fidayin were usually
young men devoted to the ismaili cause
of hasan sabah
and later the nizari imams and were
given great honors for their sacrifices
many stories are told about these fiday
and their many assassinations
how they terrorize the whole middle east
through their activities
many of these stories are legendary
tales told by the crusaders and other
outsiders
and often present a rather a historical
or skewed version of events
much of which has nonetheless become
common knowledge including the parts
about smoking hashish
but it is certainly true that these
fedais and their method of
assassination became a key strategy for
the nizaris at this time
they would be sent on missions to kill
political opponents or
other general people who had posed a
serious threat to the
nizari state in various ways to get
close to some of these people the fidahi
sometimes had to disguise themselves
and infiltrate the circles of important
people
in order to go undetected they could for
example
enter into service as slaves or servants
of a target
biding their time for a very long time
until the right moment to strike
presented itself
a lot of the time these fedais were
immensely successful
they even managed to assassinate the
fatimid caliph imam al-amir biakham
allah
and even two ambassadors caliphs and
mustadisid
and later his son arashid the very high
success rate
as well as the well not entirely a
unique but certainly
unusual methods managed to strike fear
into their enemies at the time who often
responded very harshly
by doing things like massacring the
ismaili
communities or smiley populations in
certain cities that they were ruling
most of these fiday were dispatched from
alamout by hassan sabah and his
successors
including the new nizadi imams who would
appear as leaders shortly thereafter but
a lot of activity
also took place in syria that other
major region of influence for the
nizaris at the time
and it is here that we really start to
see some strong connections
to assassin's creed the nizaris in syria
used similar military
techniques as their leaders in persia
had by conquering several mountain
fortresses
including the great stronghold of
massive
and it is here that from the 1160s
the nizaris managed to establish
themselves more firmly
under the leadership of a very
significant figure
rashida din sinan referred to in
crusader accounts
as the old man of the mountain or in
terms of the
my best man to complete a mission more
important than any that has come before
and you return to me with nothing but
apologies and excuses
sinan was so powerful and successful
that he
and his syrian community almost became
entirely independent from the imams in
alamout
it was under the leadership of rashid
that the syrian ismailis the
syrian assassins in other words reached
the height of their power
from the mountain fortress of massive he
would conduct the activities of the
syrian nizari state
as well as dispatched fidays to go on
missions of assassination
the political situation of this
community was perhaps even more complex
than that of alamout
the crusades were in full force in this
region with crusaders and templars
fighting with various muslim forces
including the newly emerging salaheddine
or saladin
and his armies rashida din would take
various positions in this chaos
sometimes being on friendly terms with
the franks who ruled in jerusalem
at other times aligning himself with
saladin on various occasions
assassinations took place on people of
all kinds of affiliations
many of which were directly attributed
to rashidin
and his assassins saladin himself was
attacked on two occasions by fidays
but survived both assassination attempts
another very famous event took place in
april 1192
when the new frankish king of jerusalem
marquis conrad of monteferrat
was assassinated entire the assassins
had disguised themselves as christian
monks and gotten close to the king by
earning his confidence before
well murdering him while the
perpetrators have never been determined
definitively
many accounts suggest that this was
indeed the work of fida is sent by the
old man of the mountain
it is interesting that while rashidin
would align himself with
various different forces including the
crusaders or the
franks in jerusalem the nizadis
in syria always seemed to have kind of a
hard time with the templars in
particular
the knights templar was a christian
military order of
basically mercenaries that participated
in the crusades and defended jerusalem
from muslim invasion
and even when the nizadis tried to be on
friendly terms with the francs in
jerusalem
the templars would hinder these
processes
the nizadis also called assassins often
clashed with the templars in
military battles and during some periods
had to pay monetary tribute to them
this general conflict can be seen for
example in an event when an emissary was
sent by rashida din
to king amalrik in jerusalem to
negotiate peace
after the negotiations seemed to have
gone well the templars were so angered
that they ambushed and killed the
emissary on his return journey
all of this is of course especially
interesting when compared
with the famous video game series where
the
conflict between the assassins and the
templars
is kind of the main story beat
throughout all of the games it's like
the main
conflict in the entire series this
conflict is of course
hugely exaggerated and
a lot of creative freedom has gone into
this but we can
see from the historical context that it
is at least someone based on a real
very tense relationship between the
assassins in
in syria and the templars rashida din
sinan died in 1193
likely of natural causes he didn't like
the
alim of the game's turn evil and
hypnotize an entire city
instead he is widely remembered as one
of the most significant leaders in the
history of ismailism
having established a strong nizadi state
in syria
as well as furthering the tactic of
deploying fidays or assassins
to perform political murder the
assassins or more properly called fidae
in this context are legendary at this
point and rightfully so
over the course of the alamut period of
nizadi ismailism
they carried out a number of
assassinations on high-ranking political
opponents
from judges to governors sultans and
even
caliphs as we have seen they would use
clever techniques of infiltration
disguising themselves as monks as
servants
or infiltrating the inner circles of
their targets
and biding their time before striking
some of the leaders of the nizaris like
hassan sabah in alamoth
and rashida deen in syria and in the
fortress of massive
has also become legendary figures they
are often portrayed as kind of cold
calculating
military leaders but we have to remember
that
most accounts and most stories that we
have of these figures
come from political opponents they come
from crusaders or by
other muslims only by people basically
who saw them as either political
opponents or as
heretics and so a lot of the
portrayals of these individuals should
of course be taken with a grain of salt
as they are
most likely very skewed so we should try
to look
past these very biased depictions of
these individuals
we mustn't forget that hassan sabach was
also an intellectual
a philosopher who wrote treatises on
ismaili esoteric doctrine
and similar things can also be said
about the old man of the mountain
these mountain fortresses often house
great libraries that contain books on
various
philosophical religious and scientific
subjects
as we saw earlier nasira din atuzi one
of the greatest scientists and scholars
in the history of the islamic world
spent several decades in alamut under
the patronage of the nizari imam
and studied in the library there sadly
all of this material was destroyed
when the mongols invaded in 1256
they managed finally to conquer alamout
they burned down the library they
destroyed the mountain fortresses
and thus ended the period known as the
alamout period
and that's also the period of the famous
assassins
but the story lives on despite all of
this
not only in legendary chronicles of the
time but also in the popular media of
today
like for example in the assassin's creed
games even though the story there is of
course greatly exaggerated and altered
and even such a thing as the word itself
assassin
has become a standard word in the
english lexicon
referring to any kind of sanctioned
murder it's always very interesting to
see how such an everyday word
has very fascinating origins in a
particular religious
movements of shia muslims in the middle
ages
who became so strongly associated with
the fidays and their techniques of
murder
that they were to give name to the
entire concept
just like we talked about in my previous
video about the history of coffee and
tea
a lot of everyday obvious things that we
don't think about
can sometimes have very strong and
interesting connections to
religions and religious history
i'll see you next time this video was
brought to you by our patreon community
including the new ones absolute and
thomas blase i would also like to as
always thank my top tier
uh patreons including adam schreibe
amulet
faris badawi hanan fikri mary carmen
ordonez mohammed moda sir raid
richie abel stewart cleland said hashemi
say jaffari thomas blaise again wild
muhammad and
wasif khan thank you all so much and if
anyone else wants to become a patron
i'll leave the links to that stuff
in the description i'll see you next
[Music]
time
you